want to know because if you put a title
in that on your dreams
I just sensibility of all the time I
don't miss or anything I think you're
shooting yourself like I said it's like
a timeline so whatever their degrees are
girl okay if we stick with us you know
there'd be no actors actors
the state whether what it's not amazing
it's so easy to give up so we got to get
into a reason it's not about them I
didn't want to come out here I want to
judge you Theatre in the artist and
whatever happiness turn that into the
right reasons and I think
ourselves out cause everyone's gonna get
a shot one way or not yeah and shaken
advantage
just because I'd never like to lose I
think it comes back to when I played I
don't like them those are cute and just
give you my oversized okay crystal
because even when they're doing well
at a time I said I'm going to give up
competition whatever then you should not
be in this vessel for each one
so go back to school nursing become a
lawyer then you can tell others how
you're the Archaea decisions in general
you